[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who
doesn't want to be your monkey wrench
and what sound does a gorilla's doorbell
make
king kong we're already off to a
terrible start with the crap jokes
but nothing's gonna stop me smiling as
godzilla versus kong
is finally out on hbo max throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down the ins and outs of the story
it's ending and discussing the super
secret surprise villain
that was shown in every trailer for the
film obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the movie then i
highly recommend that you check yourself
and check out now
smash that thumbs up button if you enjoy
the video and don't forget to subscribe
to the channel for breakdowns like this
each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into godzilla versus
kong
okay so there's a lot to unpack from
this movie and i will be doing a slight
recap to discuss the major plot points
as i feel you need to know them in order
for the ending to make sense
however if you just want to skip ahead
then time codes will be linked below
and the film itself centers heavily
around the hollow earth
this is a real life theory that first
hit the mainstream back in the 17th
century
after edmond haley theorized that earth
had an almost onion-like structure
with several layers to it though never
proven the theory still remains popular
in conspiracy circles
and is something that makes the basis
for this movie in the titles for the
film we discovered that there was an
expedition to antarctica in 1926 that
unearthed its existence
after the people who participated in it
disappeared the event was quickly
declassified by the government
but they've kept a close eye on it as
there exists a powerful energy source
within its cavinus tunnels
it's the arise throughout the film that
this if honest will be able to destroy
godzilla
and it sort of becomes the mcguffin for
the boring human subplot that gets in
the way of the two titans of terror
tearing each other in from them which
let them fight yeah that's that's all i
want to say
now the movie picks up five years after
the events of godzilla king of the
monsters
and we joined kong who's currently
living in a simulated skull island
at monarch outpost 236 after the skull
island mission that took place in the
70s made his existence government
knowledge
he's been placed in the production of
man and woman
overseen by eileen andrews and her
adopted daughter gia
who can communicate with him through
sign language sorry guerrilla sign
language
he's lived somewhat of a peaceful
existence until he starts chucking trees
about
this is something that we saw him doing
in his solo movie when the helicopters
first arrived at skull island
and it's it's a pretty crappy strike
that i i don't even know why i bothered
including however
linking back to skull island we learned
that gia is actually the last of the iwa
aka the tribe that we met in that movie
who lived somewhat of a symbiotic
existence with the creature
now because he's an alpha titan the
organization know that this puts him in
direct competition with godzilla
and thus they've kept him shielded from
the monster in the build-up to the film
a lot of people wondered how kong would
end up going toe-to-toe with the monster
due to the size difference many of them
my wife included
often say that size doesn't matter but
there was some people scratching their
heads
over how he would be a formidable
opponent however we do learn in the
movie that kong has continued to grow
and that the dome is becoming too small
to stabilize him
now in these five years the shadowy
organization apex cybernetics
have managed to build a gigantic robotic
titan known as mechagodzilla
using the head of the ghidorah that we
saw at the end of king of the monsters
ishiro sara zawa's son ren has helped to
perfect this titan killing machine
and he's able to telepathically control
it through neural link-ups designed by
apex in the build-up to the film it was
said in the leaks that there were a lot
of similarities with pacific rim
and i feel like these moments especially
ape that film
pun not intended well well it was a bit
intended now the experiments are highly
secretive
but bernie hayes the host of the titan
conspiracy theory podcast
has managed to infiltrate their
organization through posing as an
employee
haze and earth some of their dodgy
dealings but before he can really get
anywhere beyond seeing eye to eye with
mecha g
godzilla shows up to eat some fish and
ships
turns out you either die king of the
monsters or live long enough to see
yourself become a villain
and the titan has now become the latest
victim of cancel culture
due to his constant attacks on their
facilities madison russell however
realizes that there's stranger things
going on hey
and she heads out with a friend rusty
from deadpool 2 to get to the bottom of
it
realizing that their operations are
going down worse in an amber her tweet
apex enlists the help of nathan lind
nathan is a hollywood theorist at
dresses like marty mcfly
and he also helps out because he used to
work for monok believing that genetic
memory exists within all creatures
lin theorizes that all beings wish to
return to their evolutionary source
and thus they team up with monarch and
kong to lead them on a journey to the
center of the hollow earth
now kong is taken across the ocean and
on the way we can see that the character
is sedated by giant green canisters
which is strapped on a collar around his
neck this is actually a callback to the
original versus film between the pair
in which the humans used a similar sort
of liquid in order to sedate him
now it's on this voyage that godzilla
arrives for the showdown at sea
that sees him not only beating kong but
also most of the monarch and apex
vessels
the first battle doesn't disappoint and
you can see why they put
so much hype into this fight as it's an
awesome action scene
that feels fit for a king kong up until
this point i feel like it was the best
scene in the monster verse
and by far was with the weights and
delays that have seen this film push
back several times
when discussing the scene with ign
director adam wingard
talked about how he wanted to pay homage
to jaws in several ways
and we see this not only with godzilla's
dorsal fins soaring through the water
but also the boat that he pulls under
with him shot similar to the barrel
scene it forces the humans into freeing
kong
so that he can not only protect himself
but also them
the battle goes underwater and godzilla
clearly beats kong
making my boy take his first l in a long
line of them
however the humans disable the engines
on their ships
so that the g-man thinks that they're
destroyed and godzilla retreats
realizing that he'll come back as soon
as they start them up again
the humans carry kong across the sky and
what is a reference to the hot air
balloon moment that appeared in 1962's
king kong vs godzilla
along with kong monarch enter the hollow
earth and find an almost prehistoric
landscape that's similar to skull island
due to the ceiling and ground bug being
parts of the earth
there are severe gravitational anomalies
and the hollow earth is protected with
natural forces similar to kong's home
elsewhere madison her buddy josh in
bernie managed to sneak into the apex
facility because their security is
absolutely terrible
it's worse than my best mates riddled
richard's antivirus protection
and i don't mean on his computer i said
hey you haven't i
have not now here they discover apex
running combat simulations against skull
crawlers
their continued testing alerts godzilla
once more and he travels to hong kong to
attempt to destroy the manufactured
titan
in the hollow earth we're introduced to
new monsters including nuzuki
and also warbat the former is a giant
winged snake that we see too of getting
their butts handed to them
after our boy does some kung fu the
latter are large bat-like creatures
that attack him inside the giant tomb
that's there for his species
this showcases some of the skeletons
left behind in the war between the
gajira and kong over the millennia
and also teases that their great rivalry
now this used to be the kong's home
but since they died out it's become
somewhat of a shrine
along with the history lesson kong also
gains an axe
the blade of which is made from a gajira
dorsal fin
capable of being charged by the energy
source the activation of this is sensed
by godzilla
who blasts his way through from hong
kong into the hollow earth chamber
kong travels through the crater and in
the city they fight it out which leads
to another amazing action scene
it's like a live-action rampage fight
and it overall elevates the movie to be
the best in the monster vs saga so far
i definitely feel like they brought
everything out that they could to make
it so that the fights felt impactful
throughout
another human part slightly bogged down
the overall story
these bits really shine what doesn't
shine though is my boy kong
who takes another solid l and with
godzilla weakened
apex's ceo walter simmons uses the
hollow earth's power to fully charge
mechagodzilla
however this backfires and ren is killed
due to the overcharge
which allows the consciousness of
ghidorah to take over the machine
and it murders walter during his bad guy
monologue before it ventures to the
surface to avenge its death
the humans manage to revive kong and jia
convinces him to join godzilla's side
without a save mothra joke in sight now
the tagline of the film
is one will fall and i do feel like this
was slightly misleading
as i was half expecting a death but
obviously these monsters crush it at the
box office
so warner brothers don't want to destroy
what is quickly becoming their tentpole
franchise
in the control room bernie josh and
madison help the short circuit
mechagodzilla
and godzilla powers up kong's axe which
he uses to destroy the mechanical
monster
with just godzilla and kong left
standing it looks like the two are gonna
face down against one another but the
pair have somewhat
found a respect that their ancestors
could not and they go their separate
ways to form their own kingdoms in their
respective realms
and this takes us to the hollow earth
which has now become a kong monitoring
station
nathan is now likely singing come on
eileen as he her and gia
worked together to turn the habitat into
his new home something that the monster
was searching for the entire film
because skull island was devastated by
storms that wiped out the eewee
he had been left without one but this
ancestral plane allows him to finally
have a domain once more to rule over
the monster verse has been very strict
over not calling him king kong
but now at this point i feel like this
is cemented according to the original
plot leaks on the film which pretty much
got this entire story bang on
that showing of the movie revealed that
kong was going to be the king of the
hollow earth
whilst godzilla would remain king of the
monsters these separate domains allowed
them to be the alphas of their
respective kingdoms
without upsetting the natural order of
events though we can't verify exactly
what was shown at the screening due to
ndas
this does make a lot of sense and also
opens the doors to sequels that center
around them
and their respective kingdoms now adam
wingard has done several interviews
since the movie released overseas
and he explained that the film doesn't
have a post-credits scene
because he didn't want to pigeonhole
himself into going down a certain path
though we now know that the movie was
extremely successful in its opening
weekend
they obviously didn't know how big it
would be when making it and thus
didn't want to restrict themselves to
one story avenue going forward
i think this is probably quite a smart
thing to do as seeing charles dance at
the end of king of the monsters
then being completely removed for this
film makes little sense and it means
that they can just focus on that story
as
and when they get to it no doubt the
pair will be back but it might be some
time before we see them on screen
together
now as for my thoughts on the film i
think you already know what my
criticisms will be
as they're the thing that's always
lobbied against the movies in this saga
the human drama is pretty flat on the
most part
and there's not even really any
relationships this time around
so it's difficult to get attached to any
of the characters
whereas in the prior monster based
movies there's either been
a brother and sister a love story
or a family driving the storyline here
the characters might as well just be put
in place to set one plot point
and take our characters to the next
that's pretty much what they get to do
with kong
and even people like millie bobby brown
who was a big part of the last movie
get reduced to having very little to do
it's the same with her dad who
even though he starred in peter
jackson's king kong doesn't really get
anything to do at all he's pretty much
just there to read text messages
and that's a shame because he was such a
big part i feel like he could have
removed their entire arcs out of the
film
and it would have been pretty much the
exact same movie with little lust
however saying that i i just want to say
congratulations to the team
for all the monster scenes and action
moments they really saved the film in my
eyes and completely elevated it
every time godzilla and kong are on
screen they're just dynamite to the
movie
that makes it exhilarating to watch your
heart's pumping
you're on the edge of your seat and
these scenes are the best that we could
have got
there's several bits where i was
expecting martin scorsese to pop on
screen
and say this is cinema because it works
so well
so um you know we're talking about this
i do feel bad dinging the movie for
having crap human subplots
when that's not what we're here for what
we really want to see is a showdown
between big monsters
and this really delivers on the promise
out of all the monster versus movies i
feel like this reigns at the top with
godzilla in second place
which i insist you go back and watch
after that for me
it's probably skull island and lastly is
king of the monsters because i
just just thought it was pretty meh i
was kind of good at that kong took
consecutive elves back to back
as i would have loved to have seen him
get at least one winning but
i'm sure fans will debate all the time
like saying well he was sedated he was
sedated
now it is a shame that due to the
pandemic we can't all experience this in
the cinema as i think it would have been
a blast to watch
but unfortunately that's just the way
the world is that being said though
godzilla versus kong was a blast
and it gets a seven out of ten obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
movie so make sure you comment below and
let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
show on the 30th of april in which we're
giving away three copies of the 4k
version of zack snyder's justice league
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning
is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
falcon in the winter soldier which will
be linked on screen right now
we went over the second episode from top
to bottom and pointed out all the cool
easter eggs in it